the jurgen experience one thing i will
say about spotify layout though like as
a fan you know i want to tune into the
pods sometimes i find it hard to to
watch on my tv yeah so that sucks
yeah they're gonna it's eventually gonna
be on all platforms in terms of like
television-based platforms
well right now it's on uh chromecast and
it's gonna be on it's on google play
and they're working on roku and apple tv
they're working on a bunch of different
platforms that'll eventually be but it's
not as smooth as it probably should have
been when it first when we first
transferred over in december but they
just weren't ready for the volume
they had never had a show first of all
they they created video because of the
conversation we had about this podcast
yeah they wanted the podcast to be audio
only
and my manager was like
think about the elon musk moment when
elon musk is smoking weed it's huge that
is a viral moment that only happens with
video
where elon's like it's legal right i'm
like yeah it's totally huge i saw the
painting yeah and then it's i remember i
was at the airport
and uh i had sunglasses and a hat and
i'm on my way to vegas and i'm like
looking at this cnn monitor it shows
elon smoking weed on my podcast and i'm
like oh no
what a trip i was like what have i done
but those moments those crazy viral
moments um they don't exist without
video and my manager said that to
spotify spotify was like you're right
and then they started working on the
video platform
and then
you know there's been a lot of weirdness
like um
a lot of uh you know we're talking about
like how people
get a sense of who a person is without
actually communicating with them without
being there with them and you could
define someone or you know have this
like um
distorted perception of who a person is
without actually
communicating with them
that's one of the things that happened
with spotify with like some of their
staff where they thought i was
transphobic or thought i was like a bad
person i saw one of their staff say that
i was a shock jack
shock jock
like that i'm not even remotely yeah
you're just a dude with a mic yeah i
always tell people because sometimes
i know he's a comic and stuff so i see
you more as a comic than anything
and
you didn't intend on this becoming as
big as become it's just organically
grown and people tuned in because they
want to tune in you're not
you're not being force-fed down people's
throat they're like choosing to listen
to you yeah but when i've actually
on purpose never advertised for this
show i've never asked people to watch it
i've never gone on television shows and
promoted it i've never taken out any
billboards or ads spotify did some of
that stuff when i switched over to them
but i never did any of it so i used to
get so odd when people hold you to the
same standards as like cnbc or these
entities
or you're just like a guy with a mic
yeah you know what i mean but they don't
like it because it gets much more of an
audience than them that's what freaks
them out when you have these huge
multinational corporations that have
thousands of employees and they can't
even touch the amount of reach that a
guy with a podcast has yeah that's
madness for them i've seen clips of your
like first episode or whatever or
pictures it's like absurd it's absurd
you know
it's been an organic
thing you can see yeah you can see how
it grows but it's also a lesson to all
these other comics too like what's the
difference well the difference i grind i
just keep going yeah it's the same thing
with you that got you good at comedy
what got you good at comedy stage time
what gets you good at podcasts podcast
time you don't have no one who's doing
it
even just doing my podcast because
especially during the past what's it
called dance time for ximena or dance
hour dancehall mounted
just uh when the pandemic hit you lean
into what is available to you so stand
up wasn't really there
so i doubled down on the podcast i got
like a nicer space to film it in like a
nice studio and
i've been doing it for two years now and
obviously i'm better at it now than i
was
first
three months or whatever it's a skill
it's a skill and time is time and any
anything that you do
and i've just found
it it's helped with my stand-up even
uh because talking is talking
and even though this is conversational
it just wires your brain and you have
certain pathways
where you are comfortable formulating
thought
and it's conducive to podcasting and
then also stand up yeah
well the best example that is bill burr
yes with his monday morning podcast
because he's [ __ ] orienting just him
and the microphone yeah and he's so
prolific with the stand-up because he's
developed that muscle of creation and
also i'm kind of an introvert like i
don't really talk a lot just like
if i'm at a party or something i'm not
like life of the party or anything
that's kind of laying the cut so having
a weekly podcast where i have to expunge
at length for an hour or two hours
whatever it may be
it forces you you have no guests uh
sometimes i do like i had joel list on
uh i love joe list i love jealous too
yeah yeah it's hilarious so
i'm gonna i'm gonna use my network i've
been doing stanford so i want to like
get bobby on eventually and just whoever
wants to do it to like get some guests
but i also like not having it be so
guest dependent whether people just like
me and my co-host yeah and
yeah
yeah so just like i've just found that
podcasting has lent itself to
uh elevating my stand up even
for sure
it not just elevated my stand up but it
elevated who i like the way i think
about things it elevated my ability to
communicate with people like i'm way
better at talking to people now
um i'm critical about my ability to talk
to people like
if i um
i have a conversation that's clunky this
is so weird like just a dinner
conversation i say something clunky or
it bothers me like i wake up in the
middle and i take a leak and it bothers
me i'm [ __ ] i'm
like
if people think i'm like cocky
i'm the most hyper critical person that
i know i [ __ ] hate everything i do
yeah i have to accept that everything i
like when i release a special i don't
ever watch them i edit them and then i
never watch them again i just release it
i don't want to watch myself i hate
myself i'm the same way dude that way
yeah like sometimes trolls will like
write some [ __ ] or whatever i think what
trolls don't understand is
i don't love everything i do of course
you're probably right yeah for sure
there's no other way to get good
you have to be hyper critical yeah but
the thing about being an artist or
whatever is
you have to put yourself out there good
or bad
you have to put yourself out there yeah
and if you get that you get that some
people like it some people don't but i
took the swing and there it is and
i don't love everything that i've done
the thing is they didn't take the swing
the trolls didn't take the swing and one
of the things that they have the ability
to do is they have to ability to
criticize you and criticize everyone
without looking at themselves and that's
why they focus so much time on
criticizing other people yeah i've
almost found though that
i don't get mad at that i understand it
for what it is but also i think that
troll forum or whatever like that's
their comedy store
that's their outlet yeah for sure yeah
and i get it well that's why i think uh
comments are important i used to think
the comments are like like i had a
friend reach out when i said that um
i want to figure out a way to for
spotify to put comments on the episodes
and they were like don't [ __ ] do that
this friend reached out and he was like
that is the worst part of youtube is the
comments i'm like
i don't know if that's right i mean it's
sometimes the worst part of the comments
but also sometimes it gives people the
ability and i i can't read them and one
of the reasons why i can't read them is
i don't i don't have the time
i don't have the time to engage with all
these different ideas and opinions and i
think that it is look if i was being
disingenuous with my criticism of myself
i probably could use comments to keep me
in line but i'm [ __ ] ruthless with
myself like i'm good and i don't want to
hurt my feelings i'm the same way uh i
kind of create i put it out there and i
don't need to go it's i always liken
going in the lob the comment section
it's like lord of the rings you put a
battle helmet on
fight the orcs yeah you you fight
yeah it's just not emotional as an
artist
there's no good there's no good at going
into the comments it's not healthy
so it's not healthy to hear the good
stuff either yeah praising you like but
i understand the value and that it's
community-based and yeah that's great
that they have a forum there's a value
there's a value in that that's where
youtube shines i don't have to be privy
to that i can just create blast it out
and just worry about me
that's where youtube shines over all
other forums is that they have that
comment section i think that spotify
needs to recognize that i've tried to
talk to them about that
and there's been some discussion about
putting con but one of the things they
said was like if we put comments on your
podcast we have to put comments on
everybody's podcast yeah so um but i go
why why just put them on mine i don't
give a [ __ ] just put them on mine
so i it's like these people that are
commenting even if they have criticism
they're [ __ ] listening man yeah like
sometimes they hate me and sometimes
they love me they're entitled to it but
that's just like me i don't like me all
the time yeah
i have this thought i go sometimes like
when somebody writes something shitty i
want to be like do you think you can top
what's in my brain yeah it's impossible
do you think you're a better troll in my
brain you're not there when i wake up at
five in the morning angry at myself when
i go to the gym you have no idea yeah
the biggest trolls in my head good luck
yeah good luck good luck yeah there's
[ __ ] monsters in my head good luck
catch new episodes of the joe rogan
experience for free only on spotify
watch back catalog jre videos on spotify
including clips easily seamlessly switch
between video and audio experience on
spotify you can listen to the jre in the
background by using other apps and can
download episodes to save on data cost
all for free spotify is absolutely free
you don't have to have a premium account
to watch new jre episodes you just need
to search for the jre on your spotify
app go to spotify now to get this full
episode of the joe rogan experience